la tension ne redescend donc pas autour
de l'ukraine anthony blinken annonce un
déplacement à kiev demain mercredi le
secrétaire d'état américain s'inquiètent
de la situation à la frontière où des
milliers de soldats russes seraient
masse et il ya eu un coup de fil tout à
l'heure entre blinken et le russe lavrov
à moscou dit vouloir des réponses
concrètes à ces demandes notamment sur
la fin des deux larges issement de
l'otan bonjour mathieu mabin vous
retrouva à washington la menace russe
est prise au sérieux par les américains
oui on assiste à une nouvelle tentative
de la diplomatie américaine de maintenir
les négociations entre moscou et
washington mais sous respiration
artificielle disons le la dernière mise
en garde de moscou révèle que le
dialogue restera au point mort vous
l'avez rappelé en substance tant que le
bloc occidental entendez par là les
américains et l'otan n'aura pas accédé
aux exigences formulées par les
diplomates de vladimir poutine à genève
en début de semaine dernière or
concrètement ces demandes consiste à
recréer un équilibre de force
directement inspirée de l'ère soviétique
ce qui vous l'imaginez bien est
totalement irréaliste et surtout très
impopulaire ici à washington depuis la
fin de la guerre froide et notamment
l'installation de bases américaines en
pologne au début de la décennie 90 les
armées américaines disposent d'une ligne
de défense face à la russie qui courent
de varsovie à ankara mais avec quelques
failles dans le dispositif on pense
évidemment à l'ukraine est également à
la géorgie dans une moindre mesure et à
mesure que la relation avec moscou s'est
dégradée ces dernières années à mesure
que la tension américaine a également
été mobilisé par sa posture face à la
chine les présidents américains
successifs n'ont eu de cesse de vouloir
avancer les pions de l'otan sur ce qui
pourrait donc devenir une ligne de
confrontation l'inquiétude de washington
où reposent donc aujourd'hui sur ce
blocage dans le dialogue diplomatique
qui empêche d'une part ne serait ce
qu'une amorce de retrait militaire russe
à la frontière ukrainienne et surtout
qui semble conduire inexorablement les
deux blocs à se défier sur un terrain de
plus en plus militaire cette fois les
cyber attaques russes des incursions de
forces spéciales en territoire ukrainien
et côté américain une densification des
survols de la frontière par l'ufr force
ne sont que quelques exemples
quelques exemples rappelons qu'en cas de
dégradation majeure de la situation et
d'un glissement de la confrontation
diplomatique vers un registre armés les
pays de l'union européenne membre de
l'otan serait en première ligne et donc
la défense européenne or il est vrai que
l'allemagne a toujours été l'un des
points de fragilité de la politique
européenne de sécurité et de défense
cette même allemagne si dépendante du
gaz russe est donc une allemagne dont
l'affirmation de l'adhésion à une
posture occidentale commune se révèle de
plus en plus indispensable merci
matthieu mabin depuis washington c'est
un